my good buddy ed bouche ed of the
Pittsburgh post-gazette and and Edie
please tell me what is going on in
Pittsburgh right now Clark what isn't
going on Pittsburgh right now
you know only only the San Antonio
Browns story could knock out the lady on
bail story right huge all pros who
almost surely won't be with this team
next year and you know it's been one
thing after another for a couple years
now and it's there's so much drama has
been involved this team it's a wonder
it's a wonder they went nine and six and
one this year not not you know six nine
and one you know one of the things
though too is I've said this before
competing against the Steelers when I
was in the National Football League was
they were the one of the more buttoned
up organizations like you know when you
played against the Steelers there wasn't
much talking
they would come out run the football
play action play great defense shake
your hand and keep it moving and now it
seems that all this drama is coming out
each week whether like you mentioned
brown the levee on bail situation to
happen in beginning of a season Ben
Roethlisberger calling out teammates
Mike Tomlin have to answer questions
each week and and I'm taking care of
this internally when did this all change
for that organization you know it's been
gradual Kirk but I think what happened I
think it's more of us not that they
didn't have stars here before but I
think it's been fueled by the star
system I really do you know the
so-called killer bees' with Ben
Roethlisberger and labium Bell and
Antonio Brown if you want to add
martavis Bryant right now he was part of
the drama last year as well so um did
they just you know they're there on
social media and I'm not saying all of
them but the author on social media and
I mean Antonia Brown had his own
Instagram guy following them all over
the place of practices it's just it got
out of hand and I think what we're going
to see is them
he tried to put it back in the box by
getting rid of some of these bones not
getting rid of Antonia well we'll
probably trade Antonio Brown but lay
beyond Bel probably become a free agent
I don't think they're gonna tag him
again and leave on his own so and do you
think next year we hear a the 2019 NFL
season we get there week one the
pittsburgh steelers is Antonio Brown on
that roster next year I don't think so
just going by what the team president
art Maroney said nah he doesn't envision
that happening and he still we talked to
him yesterday Art Rooney and he still
hasn't heard from Brown nobody has at
least nobody in charge so it just seems
like it's it can't happen at this point
they can't bring them back at blue
shadow the Pittsburgh post-gazette
joining the Rich Eisen show Kirk
Morrison here in for Rich and in it who
do we look to in terms of is it the
organization is it Mike Tomlin like what
what's not who do we blame here for like
you mentioned the killer bees but at
some point who was the person that has
to put a stop to it well I think
removing the Antonio Brown is going to
be a big part of doing that they do have
some team leaders in there marquees
Pouncy kam Hayward to name two of many
Ben Roethlisberger and I wouldn't be
surprised to see a big gathering
sometime in the spring where they go
over all this stuff because they have to
put a stop to it they yes they went
thirteen and three through a lot a whole
lot of drama in 2017 but then got rubbed
out by Jacksonville at home and then
first playoff game so did they haven't
been to a Super Bowl now in ten years
and it's the they have the talent to be
doing that kind of thing they've only
won three playoff games since then you
know and in reading your article this
morning and in you know you talking
about how Art Rooney has said
they're committed to a contract
extension with Ben Roethlisberger and
not so much mike tomlin a head coach yet
like how does that scenario play out is
it ownership choosing quarterback over
coach or is it they are thinking of an
extension but right now take care of the
quarterback first before they can think
about Mike Tomlin in the future yeah I
think it's the latter Kirk they have to
get they want to get the players done
first Ben is do a five million roster
bonus in March and by doing a new
contract they could fold that into a
signing bonus and lessen the the pain on
the cap this year so that that would be
a one priority they have a while I've
many times they've announced coaching
extensions in training camp so they have
time there art did not say he won't do
an extension he didn't say he was going
to do one either but you know I'm sure
they have want to sit down and talk hey
I'm I'm betting that Michael is gonna
want to raise on a new contract and they
might have an issue there I don't know
of how much it would be you know and
internally within the coaching staff so
we've seen guys leave whether it's now
we see Mike Munchak taking the job over
in Denver we know Todd Haley's and left
the organization as the offensive
coordinator he goes and takes a job
elsewhere and then also to the comments
of Bruce Arians who is now the head
coach in Tampa you know talking about
Antonio Brown as a diva wide receiver
has there been a fraction within the
coaching staff and I forgot about the
Joey Porter coach would not be back next
year
how was Tomlin looking at his staff now
yeah I think when when Todd was here he
has that kind of personality that there
may have been some kind of you know
fracture there if you will with some of
the coaches um even though he did a good
job coaching here but now you know Mike
Munchak is a separate case he left
because his daughter and DA and
granddaughter are
in Denver and they said it was the only
job he would have taken and I believed
him he's 58 going on 59 and he said
there's more to life than you know
basically football but I don't think
it's abnormal they've made changes the
Bruce Arians one a number of years ago
was art Rooney made that change did not
renew his contract Todd Haley same thing
his contract wasn't renewed but I mean
you have coaching changes all the time
all on all teams I don't think it's that
the net normal there he's ambushed ed of
the Pittsburgh post-gazette joining the
Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison in for
Rich but has has Mike Tomlin maybe lost
the locker room a little bit and
depending on how they handled the
Antonio Brown could he maybe regain that
locker room if he's lost it well he lost
Antonio Brown I don't think he really
lost the rest of the locker room um I
think they respect him and I think he's
a good coach but the Antonio Brown thing
has just gotten bigger than anything and
he's been a burn his butt for a while
recall that Facebook live video that a
Anil Brown did in the locker room I'm
surprised he they welcomed him back
after that one but he was such a good
player is such a good player that you
have to weigh one against the other you
know I just look at me I'm like another
story on him today and unbelievable
right most ever receptions and yards in
a six-year period by any receiver in the
history of the NFL just to name a few
and he led the league and touchdowns
with 15 this year a new Steelers record
so I it's just they've overlooked some
of this stuff because of that because he
was such a good player but it it it
multiplied this year and then it came to
a head in that last week you know and
but you know we talked about Antonio
Brown lately I'm bill before the season
was went on with him Mike Tomlin's
always talked abut
seems that the quarterback Ben
Roethlisberger is either shield it from
the criticism or kind of overlooked is
it that way with you guys in Pittsburgh
or is that just something nationally
that we kind of overlooked that being is
really above the problem I don't think
he's much of the problem Kirk I mean
he's said a couple things of the
receivers they weren't you know terrible
things right I just pointed out a couple
things quarter
there have been quarterbacks who have
done that in the past I just and I think
I performed
he's got a couple Super Bowl rings I
don't think Ben has been part of the
problem he certainly hasn't skipped out
on his team the way Antonio Brown did he
hasn't missed an entire season like
lately on Bell did right or wrong I mean
that's his business but he's always been
there and and you know they really want
to give him a new contract yeah last one
for ya before I let you go outside of
the drama of the Steelers whether it's
we the guys we've named the killer beez
Brown Bill and Ben Roethlisberger
there's still some positives but now as
they point toward this off season and
they get ready for free agency in the
draft what is the biggest thing that you
think this organization needs to get
better at position wise well there's
there's gonna be there's two and now
there's three the two are on defense
they they need they still need
linebackers the Ryan shazier injury set
them back they didn't replace him well
enough this year
cornerback they need another cornerback
because their first-round pick already
burns has been a big disappointment the
last couple of years and was benched
this year and if they trade Antonio
Brown they're going to need another
top-flite receiver wow that's a lot
hopefully they can cover at all make
sure if maybe the compensation if they
do trade Antonio Brown can get them to
fill some of those gaps
always a pleasure may appreciate the
time it alright Curt
thanks for having me on oh no problem
thank you and boo [ __ ] there of the
Pittsburgh post-gazette
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience